We must fight together or the whole planet dies.
Kara, your friends are in mortal peril.
We live in things.
In all realities are about to die.
Only by taking action
can one transform doom into salvation.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
DC just dropped a brand new trailer for Justice League
Crisis on Infinite Earths
Part two
It's a three part movie.
We just got part one, so we'll break everything down.
There are a bunch of brand new characters
here, like we are Batman, Beyond Teri McGinnis is back.
in everything
that's happening with James Gunn's reboot of DC movies.
It also extends to all the animated stuff too.
So they're kind of using this Justice League
crisis on Infinite Earths saga
to reboot all the animated stuff into the DCU.
is meant to be a bit of a reference
to the way they use the original crisis
on Infinite Earths in the comics
to completely reboot DC
continuity cleaning things up in the comics
now they're just borrowing that concept for the movies.
we also found out about a live action
Batman beyond movie that they were
developing before
James Gunn's big reboot of all the movies.
so explain how that was supposed to go down to,
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I don't know when part three is coming out
and they haven't listed a release date for part
two here, but I'm assuming this is coming
in the next couple of months, maybe by the summer.
I think the idea was for them to release
all three parts of this movie this year on home video.
And it's all home video releases.
but if you have no idea what's going
on, this is basically like the tomorrow verse
version of Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths.
But they rope in a lot of other universes
and Easter eggs
for the classic DC animated universe stuff too.
some of you probably picked up on this,
but they actually brought back
Matt Ryan's Constantine voiced by a different actor.
It's actually Nolan North voicing him in the movie,
but it's meant to be.
The Constantine from the DC Animated universe.
Before they rebooted everything,
there was a teaser at the end of Constantine
House of Mystery Movie where he sees something
but you don't know what it is He was meant to be
seeing the crisis wave and everything
that's happening during crisis on infinite Earths here.
in the Spector explains that
because during Justice League apocalypse war
he sent the flash back in time
to cause another flash point reboot The Universe.
His actions directly led to this crisis
on infinite Earths.
This threatening the entire multiverse.
So for those of you that were hoping
that they would sort of rope in the DC animated movies
and make that Canada what's happening in this crisis
on infinite Earths that did happen During the movie.
The Flash seemingly doesn't remember the events
of Justice League Apocalypse war and the specter
tells him that you also bear responsibility
for what's happening now with the crisis wave.
he's basically referencing the end of Justice
League apocalypse war
in the Flash's new version of Flash point
that he causes at the end of that.
So in the movie, he takes the role
the pariah had in the original crisis.
Comics sort of serving as this Herald of doom
that's coming.
But they sort of change the plot and do it
more from the Flash's perspective.
He's meant to be this main point of view character
who's skipping backwards and forwards
inside his own timeline
without really understanding why they kind of tease
that later at the end of the movie, they're couple
other changes to the way the story goes down.
But there's this whole amazing subplot.
They give him a new origin story In the flash later
winds up using that version of a meso to help
construct the multiverse towers to stop the crisis wave
or prevent it from destroying a couple of the earths.
once the monitor brings everyone together
on his watchtower across the multiverse and tells them
what's going on, they come up with the idea
to create the multiverse towers,
which is something based from the original Crisis
Comics.
basically use them as tuning forks
to cause the planets to go out of phase of the crisis.
Wave passes through them,
but it's only three of the planets.
But one of the biggest changes during this first part
of the movie is they don't reveal the anti-monitor.
If you ever saw the DC TV version of Crisis
on Infinite Earths,
they also changed a lot
from the original crisis in the comics.
But you end up learning about the presence
of the anti-monitor
in the fact that he was behind everything much sooner.
this time in the movie
you have this version of the Monitor
and this version of Batman played by Jensen
Ackles, questioning whether or not
the crisis waves or a natural phenomenon,
or if there's some sentient force behind them.
They're basically teasing the anti-monitor
during the training for part two,
you see all the shadow creatures.
Those are minions of the Anti-Monitor in the comics,
which is why I think they just haven't revealed him
in the footage yet. Like that's a part to reveal.
Then they spend all the third movie
actually fighting him.
they're couple of funny Easter eggs
here to the birds that they wind up saving.
The three Here are Earth One Earth, two in Earth, eggs.
Earth one seems like it's meant to be
the version of Earth from the kingdom come universe,
because this older version of Superman
eventually gets married to a version of Wonder Woman.
But he explains that as after the death of his original
Lois Lane, earthquakes you probably remember
from the DCTV version of Crisis on Earth,
it was one of their big lead up crisis events.
The big crossovers that they did in the years before,
they actually did Crisis on Infinite Earths,
that was meant to be a version of Earth that was ruled
by all the Nazi versions of the characters.
There was a bit of a joke about that in the movie, too.
Like working for Nazis didn't work out for you.
they also explained that eventually in that universe,
that version of alchemy had wound up melting the polar
ice caps in Atlantis basically sunk the entire planet,
taking over the planet itself.
like how do you deal with all the Nazis?
Why don't we just sink them all?
But at the very end of the movie,
after the Flash finishes constructing,
he sort of cosmic treadmill,
I think that's what this is meant to be an Easter egg
for when he's powering up all the tuning forks,
the specter causes them to start time skipping again.
The person that he sees here in the end in
chains is supposed to be a version of Batman
who's stuck in the past, which is why his eyes go wide
when he recognizes the older flash.
Like what?
Who tells him
he has to go back And it's meant to be a universe
where Batman went back in time and has to find a way
to return to present day, which is kind of a deep
cut for the final crisis event in the comics
from a little while ago that was when Darkside's
Omega Beams seemingly killed Batman
when they really threw him back in time.
it was meant to be the third
major crisis event that DC did
after the original one,
then Infinite crisis in the early 2000s.
Then they basically ended this first movie,
teasing that in phasing
all three worlds and helping them survive.
They also altered the timelines of those worlds,
causing the tomorrow verse
version of Brainiac five and the Legion of Super-Heroes
from the future to never have existed.
that's why they start disappearing at the end.
But Supergirl does not
because Supergirl is from present day
and she just traveled into the future
to join the Legion of Super-Heroes.
one of the big twist to this movie,
though, is they actually revealed that
this version, like the tomorrow verse
version of Harbinger, is actually Supergirl.
At some point during the trailer here, it seems like
she gets turned into Harbinger by the monitor.
some sort of cosmic power up, I'm sure that will figure
into the actual plot of part two.
They don't really explain why that happened
during part one.
They just kind of tease
that it did happen at some point.
but there's a whole bunch of brand new footage
here from part two where you see Batman beyond
Terry McGinnis. He's back.
Damian Wayne, Batgirl.
Duke is in his Batman suit in the background here, too.
Like I said, the Black Shadow
creatures are minions of the Anti-Monitor.
So I think that part two will be all about them
finding out that there is a conscious force
behind the crisis wave and it is the anti-monitor
trying to actively destroy the multiverse.
Basically in the comics the anti-monitor comes from
the anti-matter universe
and he wants to destroy the positive matter.
Multiverse.
that was one of the things that made me laugh
about the whole crime syndicate in the movie
is that they basically said
they were going to punch the anti-matter wave
away, like, how are you going to punch anti-matter?
but it seems like in the part two trailer,
the crisis wave comes back.
So it just seems that the anti-monitor restarts
it and tries the same thing again.
there's a little bit of footage here of psycho Pirate
using his powers in the comics.
He was eventually compelled to serve the Anti-Monitor.
He kind of switched sides on all the heroes.
then because he was one of the survivors of crises
at the end he was doomed to remember it.
That was sort of the penance
that he served for betraying everyone.
one of the other funny Easter eggs in the background,
too, on the Monitor's platform here is that you see
a version of Peacemaker, which reminds me of my huge
theory about Peacemaker Season two in the live action.
James Gunn DCU with all this reboot stuff he's doing.
James Gunn also addressed this theory too.
Like people have been asking about it specifically.
but the idea is that a lot of characters
from the DC EU, which is where Peacemaker
Season one comes from, will survive
into the rebooted DCU movies and in most cases.
James Gunn said that they'll have a way of explaining
how everything works in the DCU,
but the characters themselves
won't spend a lot of time referencing the DCU.
like all the actors that come back as their characters
in the new DCU movies walk around talking
about the original version of the Justice League,
like Henry CAVILL'S Superman or Ben Affleck's Batman.
but my early idea for what you could do
and you could just do this
as a one off joke,
like you don't have to keep doing it over and over.
but you have Peacemaker
Act is sort of like the psycho pirate of this new DCU
because this whole thing is just spouting off crazy
conspiracy theories.
He went on and on about that during Peacemaker
Season one, most of his theories
were meant to be so crazy
that nobody ever believed anything that he said.
So you could just have him be the psycho
pirate of the new DCU, where he's the only character
that remembers that there was a previous version
of the universe and there was a reboot that happened.
speaking of reboots,
talking about that live action Batman beyond movie
right before DC hired James Gunn
to be their new version of Kevin Baggy,
they had a completely different ten year plan
for all these things the movies were building up to.
It was going to be a live action
version of Crisis on Infinite Earths.
It was going to involve Henry Cavill,
Superman, Ben Affleck's Batman, all the DCU characters
there were a bunch of scenes in the Flash movie
that they had to delete,
like a bunch of deleted scenes
that were meant to set this up.
I did a much bigger video about that, so I'll link it
at the end of this and down to the description below
because it goes on for a while.
but one of the big changes they were making during that
ten year plan is that Michael Keaton
was going to become the main version of Batman
for a while, and they would eventually be doing
a live action Batman beyond movie with him
in a new version of Terry McGinnis
there were a bunch of post-credits scenes they shot
even for Aquaman two with Michael Keaton's Batman.
They then reshot those with Ben Affleck's Batman
because they changed the order that the movies all
came out, and then they eventually hired James Gunn
and just completely wiped all those plans off the map.
Like off the books? Nope.
No, we're not going to do this.
so hopefully at some point, like in the next ten years,
James Gunn
will eventually have some kind of live action
Batman beyond movie.
But I'm not going to hold my breath for that
any time soon.
Like first
he has to introduce this brand new DCU, Batman
and Batman Brave in the Bold,
which will not be Robert Pattinson's Batman.
then maybe after like another ten years.
Then we can finally get live action.
Batman Beyond.
we'll probably get some footage
from some of the upcoming live action DC stuff
in the next several months.
they're going to be filming Superman Legacy soon.
So maybe we're lucky
we'll get some footage from the said.
James Gunn said that he was holding most of the
official trailers for that until next year, though.
whatever kind of footage we wind up getting.
Of course I will do videos for it
So be sure to enable alerts for my channel
So you don't miss any of that.
Click here to learn about all those deleted scenes,
all the Superman stuff that they had to get rid
of during the Flash movie, and click here for that
brand new Venom 3 opening scene video and learn
what Sony's plan is for their Spider-Man symbiote saga.
Thank you so much for watching
And I'll see you guys in the next one!